[Music]
let's go to
jacob in seattle what's up jacob what's
going on brother
hey dr don it's a privilege to talk to
you this morning it is a privilege to
talk to you my man so what's up
hey so i was a i have a question i was
hoping you could offer some advice um
i recently confessed uh to my wife uh
struggles with pornography um i've been
struggling with it off and on in my life
um
and
i there's these spirals of shame and
kind of the self-guilt that i fall into
um and just a fear of
being rejected for the broken person
that i am
and it
drives me to to hide
from her to to lie to her about my
sexual needs and
um
you know and just to avoid
um
you know open and honest connection with
her and i want an awesome marriage and i
know that that has no
no pardon that so i was i was curious if
you could um
offer some insight particularly to um
just
overcoming that fear of rejection and
shame spiral yeah dude well number one
thanks for calling and thanks for being
brave and talking to your wife about
what's going on
does she catch you or did you just sit
down and say hey we gotta talk
i
i
i sat her down i heard you and
i heard you and ken coleman on the
ramsay show talking about
reaching out to somebody and saying hey
i need help
and so
my wife got home from work and i
it was
the most difficult thing i've ever done
in my life was
sitting at you know down next to her and
saying hey
you know i need some help
i've been you know struggling with this
for nine months and
and hiding it from you and i don't want
that in our relationship and i really
need help because i can't get out on my
own
what was your response how'd she respond
she responded
amazingly
upset and
and hurt
as as you know as as understandable as
she should be um you know that that
feeling of you're hiding from something
from me you're lying to me
um
but with so much
love and grace as well uh and just
compassion and wanting to help me
wanting to help me heal um but a big
part of that right now was just
mending that trust that was broken in
our relationship that i broke
um so she responded really well that's
awesome man
so
how how
so there's
a jillion psychological studies about
pornography and shame and pornography
and addictive nature and pornography and
the
um
what it does to your neurochemistry
um
and so you you know all that stuff um
and so that it's
good for you for having a partner that
heard you and saw that you were hurting
um i hear a lot often i hear
men and women when they when they say
hey i'm struggling with this
um
their partner's heartbroken that they
were struggling so much and and kept the
struggle does that make sense not so
much like okay you're looking at
websites it but it's that you were in
hell and i didn't know you you didn't
trust me enough to
to reach out and so
and we're married does that make sense
and so that trust thing is often i i see
couples when they try to when they work
through this together not try to this
you all definitely work through this but
when they work through it it's about
surface level stuff like i get to check
your phone i get to see the internet so
and that's all part of it but
the deeper is
how do you learn to practice
being vulnerable in your relationship
and that's probably something you've
never ever done before is that fair
um
or you did it you got roasted
no it's
it's easy to talk about my past and to
say oh this is what i used to struggle
with but look at how i've overcome it
now and see where i'm at now see i'm
healed i'm good right
but but to say i'm actively
failing or actively struggling
right now
that's that's the part that's really
really hard
and in most you know most other areas of
my life
it's generally pretty easy for me to be
open and to be vulnerable but for some
reason this
this particular area
um
there's just a heavy
shame associated with it
that i have to
that i deal with but that so i gotcha
but that shame is an undercurrent
pornography is just the signal
the shame is underneath it
somebody told you somewhere
that
things you were into
or you're weird
or you're gross
or hey shut up i don't care or that
didn't hurt
somebody told you that
your needs
sexually and otherwise
we're less than we're not valuable we're
not important to this conversation they
we're not they're not valued in this
family
and so at some point you went
underground with it
and it probably pops up in dishonesty
with a you're like you exaggerate too
much
or it probably pops up with you're
really flirty
or it probably
pops up with
um you're over like jesus freak like you
know what i mean like super like all
into like whatever you mean i don't mean
to be ugly about it but like um
uh never miss church with your faith
community like right it pops up in these
weird places and it's us trying to out
earn that shame
who we are our our feelings are things
that we thought were funny the things
that we think are injustices somebody
told us to shut up
either explicitly or implicitly the
story we were born into was you be quiet
and we learn to be quiet and then we
start trying to achieve it i'm a
straight a student i'm the super guy i'm
the whatever
i'll always be there people come to me
with their problems i'm just rattling
off the ones that i hear a lot um and
again i don't know you at all have i hit
on any of yours
i think the closest to that would be i'm
i'm kind of the the third born middle
child peacekeeping personality there you
go okay
yes
so you will earn your
receipt at the table by making sure
i'm going to be all things to all people
i need to be okay so that everybody else
can be okay
right and but you're you're okay
you being okay is you squashing
things
and so
he like
i wish it was more complicated than this
what you've got to do
is a say i'm worth having feelings
it starts from a place of worthiness
like i get to have feelings
and i get to be super sexually attracted
to my wife
and i get to
i get to have fantasies about my wife
and we're married i'm gonna talk about
them
i'm gonna invite her into those
and that's gonna be scary
and so the word i'm gonna use is
practice
you got to start with a place of
worthiness i'm worthy
of
putting it out there
it's worth the risk
and dude you can tell her something and
she may be like what
you know what i mean
yeah and you might invite her to tell
you hers because she's got fantasies too
she's got ideas and dreams and whatever
too
and she probably doesn't know how to
tell you them
and
this is going to provide an avenue of
connection for both of you that you both
don't have
i guess
how do i
how do i
like what language can i use what things
can i put into practice to rebuild trust
with my life and to
and to practice that
open communications of
my feelings and that sense of
you know
valuing my own feelings enough to to
express them and to share them
so great question um here's two things
that i use in my house
number one
i might phrase something my wife might
phrase something with the words
i'm feeling vulnerable or i'm being
vulnerable here
and that's a we've agreed in our house
when i say i'm being vulnerable here
i feel like you're
doing this just to piss me off
or i feel like when you when i got home
you just talked about this and this and
this and you just blew me off and the
response cannot be
we're going to war it cannot be a
defensive thing it has to be a
thank you for telling me that
and it's me just practicing saying what
i'm feeling because if i get home and i
feel like my wife's blowing me off makes
me mad and then i go in my room and i
might then i go down a spiral i've been
working hard all freaking day i've been
doing this i've been it's all about me
it becomes a selfish nonsense trash and
then i come out and i'm all ready to
you know be an idiot
and so
i practice by saying i'm just being
vulnerable here
i feel like you're
ignoring me did i do something wrong i
feel like i screwed something up
and then she can say
thank you for telling me that
and then she'll look at me for a beat
and i'll say yes go ahead and respond
and she'll say
um i just gotta go to the bathroom real
bad i'm happy to see you you know what i
mean it's like something so benign i
totally misread it
um or
in your situation
i'm being totally vulnerable here
i would like to try this particular
sexual act
or
i'm interested in what really turns you
on
or
the uh john doloni erotic envelope
system that i should have patented man i
got people reaching out for it have you
heard me talk about that
yeah dude
that is the best way to practice
she gets 10 envelopes you get 10
envelopes
and
i want you to dress up in this way i
want you to fill in the blank
with whatever's in your head
and the vulnerability is you're both
going to open it you don't know who's
going to get who's and you may spend an
entire evening french kissing and
watching love actually over and over and
over again that might happen
and you may find yourself in a suit on a
who knows man whatever weird things come
up in these envelopes
but it is a way to
make the awkwardness
of your feelings
be in the envelope not in the
conversation it's a way to put it it's
again you hear me talk about writing the
letters all the time it's a way to put
it at arm's length there's a distance on
it
and then you could go okay it's in the
envelope and then she
part of the vulnerability is her going i
i don't even know how
what how does that work or i have a
question about that and then y'all are
in it now
and that's the good stuff man
and this happened with raising kids this
will happen with hey i'm not happy at my
job
uh you know pornography and sex it
becomes this just it's a way to
disconnect and numb out and unplug and
not have to deal with the potential
for rejection and you've got a life
filled of it
is everything is anything i'm saying off
um
i think
i think it's pretty close i think the i
think the biggest struggle for me is is
mostly just it's not so when it comes to
okay i wanna i want to engage sexually
in this way i'm completely satisfied
with our
our our sex life there's
i wouldn't change a thing about it
you're not satisfied with you
yeah one of the most common things
people say when they had an affair has
nothing to do with the their partner it
has to do with who they've become in
that partnership
and there's that aliveness that risk
their heart starts beating faster
and you as you're clicking away and
clicking away your heart's just being
faster and you might get caught it all
is this
it's all uh esther paralysis it's desire
it's this whole
new emotional thing that is new to us
and you can decide to have that with
your wife
but you practice it
and you lean into it so it's not about
it might be for some people it might be
about i want to try this sex position or
this like that might be it
but bigger than that
it's deciding i'm going to practice
desire i'm going to lean into the
eroticism that is my marriage
i am going to be totally vulnerable and
she might squash this
middle kids aren't don't have can't they
don't have time to be vulnerable because
they've got a whiny little younger
sibling and they've got an overbearing
older sibling
you know i don't have time for
vulnerability i got to get through the
day i need you to be okay you'd be okay
and what i'm telling you is you're worth
it all
right and i'll tell you quit looking at
porn dude stop and i know that sounds so
like dude i've got just quit
throw your computer out the window turn
the wi-fi right off just stop
just stop
okay i wish it was more complex than
that have somebody you can call
get one of those internet filters put
enough barriers in front of you
then you stop
get rid of all the streaming services
get rid of all the stuff just stop
is that fair
yeah and my wife and i we've put up
we've put up all the barriers it's i
think
more than just having the barriers
between me and finding some loophole to
finding
you know pornography
i want the kind of relationship with my
wife where i can
i can
you know
tell her
something
as it comes up or before it comes up
before it happens i want to rely more on
the relationship that i have with my
wife of openness
have an accountability partner
right now not your wife you're going to
bury your wife with that
if you call your wife four times a day
and tell her hey i really want to look
at porn right now i'm just really
struggling you're going to drown your
wife
call your accountability friend and then
at night time you tell your wife i
checked in with my accountability friend
today
she doesn't need to know the details of
what you know what i mean
yeah
and you're gonna bury her with
that have somebody you can let the raw
ugliness out with
and um
but don't don't use her as a garbage bin
yeah because what will happen is you
will start to find your body will begin
to connect those conversations with
safety
you'll begin to need to dump that stuff
on her and that's not her job her job
isn't to carry all of your crap with her
all the time
yeah right
so
do this
i'm gonna sound it's gonna sound
backwards
act better and just be different
don't over sensationalize this get an
accountability partner somebody you
trust whether it's somebody at your
local church i'm a friend of your
whoever
and you say dude i'm struggling with
this thing i'm gonna holler at you
or i'm gonna shoot you a text
and
i want here's the most important thing
okay you ready you wanna you wanna solve
this thing sooner rather than later here
it is
go to walmart go to target go somewhere
and get a small little
journal
and every time you feel an urge to look
at pornography
i want you to just stop and take an
inventory of what's happening in your in
your world
are you tired did you eat a bunch of
junk food did somebody just reject you
are you waiting to get feedback on
something from work are you feeling
lonely
what is the feeling i'm trying to get
you to create a gap a small little space
between the act of going to the website
and why why is my body trying to take
care of me why is it trying to numb out
right now
why is it taking a cheap alternative
connection right now
and once you can establish why your
body's doing that
then you can you can it's like right
when i'm about to reach for a twinkie or
a gummy candy i'll stop and go what what
am i doing oh i'm really tired right now
don't do that you're just tired
or or go eat a monster salad or go get a
steak or something
or when i find myself in my room in with
the door closed and then i'm in my
bathroom with the door closed and i'm
just sitting on the floor with instagram
and i can just go what what am i numbing
out from
what am i hiding from
hiding from nagging i'm hiding from
snacks can i have a snack and i'm just
hiding
i need to stand back up and grow up and
go back in there and if there's some
behaviors i don't like that i'm going to
lead into those behaviors and be direct
to them
i'm going to be vulnerable i'm going to
lean into that but it's just getting
that gap between the behavior and as
soon as you start to call it out you're
going to start to notice it everywhere
and then you're going to realize i don't
have to numb this
i'm sad i don't have to numb this i'm
going to call him and ask him i'll get
through my report and i don't have to
numb this i'm going to ask him for a
raise i don't have to numb this i'm
going to tell my wife i've been missing
her
or hey honey i don't feel connected to
you when you get home whatever the thing
is
but separate yourself from that act and
this goes for anybody who's trying to to
not overeat as you are making your news
resolutions listeners this is for
everybody
i'm going to stop swearing so much i'm
going to stop eating like that i'm going
to start exercising and stop sleeping it
whatever the thing is i'mma start being
nicer to my spouse or my kids whatever
it is
right when you feel the impulse to not
just pause just get a gap what's the gap
what's the gap puts the gap what's the
gap what's the gap
what is my body trying to protect me
from and when you solve that man you
solve all this stuff you solve it all
thank you so much for the call brother
jacob you got this man you got this